meine damen
an den streaming empfangsgeräten wo
immer sie uns zusehen
liebe freunde unserer gesellschaft für
politisch strategische studien
kurzstrecke werte zuseher an den
streaming empfangsgeräten eine herren
generale verehrte damen und herren
vorstandsmitglieder kameraden sowie 19
hat natürlich auch für das vereinsleben
und unseren auftrag als wer politische
verein er währende auswirkungen zum
zweiten mal begrüße ich sie daher nach
der veranstaltung am 30 juni diesen
jahres mit der buchpräsentation unserer
vizepräsidentin bundesministerin außer
dienst dr karin kneissl zu einer
streaming veranstaltung und hoffe sie
alle einen guten empfang haben
ich begann bedanke mich gleich zu beginn
beim kommandanten der
landesverteidigungsakademie
generalleutnant magister eric kubitz für
seine immer gewährte unterstützung
ich bedanke mich bei der herausbildung
film stelle für die technische
ausrichtung bewährte regieführung der
heutigen streaming veranstaltung und
auch beim leiter daher es bilder
funkstille amtsdirektor regierungsrat
inter wilfinger ich begrüße sehr
herzlich bundesminister für
landesverteidigung außer dienst general
neuer magister thomas starlinger
adjutant unseres herrn bundespräsidenten
und oberbefehlshaber des
österreichischen bundesheeres sehr
geehrter herr general
ich bedanke mich für dein interesse an
unserer gesellschaft für politisch
strategische studien insbesondere aber
auch an dem am heuten heutigen abend im
mittelpunkt stehenden referat zu 100
jahre kärntner volksabstimmung danke
mich bei den mitgliedern des vorstandes
das rating für ihre teilnahme an diesem
heutigen abend das thema unser unseres
heutigen vortrags abends lautet also 100
jahre kärntner volksabstimmung dem
heutigen vortrag haben wir fast eine
punktlandung hingelegt in der sie doch
nur drei tage nach dem hundertsten
geburtstag statt
als vortragende des heutigen abends
konnten wir eine nein die experten zu
diesem thema nämlich vor professor dr
claudia fries er fällt gewinnern hoch
verehrte frau professor namens unserer
gesellschaft zur politisch strategische
studien möchte ich mich aufrichtig und
herzlich für ihre bereitschaft bedanken
auch unter den einschränkenden
bestimmungen von corona in diesem thema
zu referieren
vielen herzlichen dank für ihr kommen
claudia fries er fällt in althofen
geboren ist ein nein die österreichische
historikerin zum thema der geschichte
kärntens das studium an den
universitäten von wien harvard und yale
schloss sie es mit der promotion zum
doktor der philosophie an der
universität wien ab und 1968 bis 1976
arbeitete sie als historikerin am
kärntner landesmuseum in klagenfurt
daneben war sie langjährige delegierte
für kärnten im österreichischen burgen
verein
seit 1997 ist sie direktorin des
geschichtsvereins für kärnten darüber
hinaus mitglied des kärntner kultur
gremiums sowie der österreichisch
slowenischen historiker kommission des
bundesministeriums für auswärtige
angelegenheiten
ich möchte sie wie ich glaube mit fug
und recht als die landes historikerin
von kärnten bezeichnen ihre
publikationen hier aufzuzählen würde den
mir zustehenden rahmen bei weitem
sprengen
ihre themen kreisen immer wieder um die
sogenannte kärntner frage sie sind damit
wirklich berufen zum heutigen thema zu
referieren
ich habe mir natürlich aus respekt
gegenüber der heutigen vortragenden aber
auch aus persönlichen und familiären
interesse in den letzten wochen sehr
intensiv mit den zahlreichen
publikationen aus anlass des hundertsten
jahrestag der kärntner volksabstimmung
beschäftigt familiäres interesse deshalb
weil ich seit beinahe 50 jahren mit
einer kärntnerin verheiratet bin und
daher alles was kärnten betrifft meine
unmittelbare aufmerksamkeit hervorruft
besonders in erinnerung ist mir ein
beitrag von universitäts professor dr
manfred rauchensteiner in der beilage
spektrum der presse vom samstag den
dritten oktober 20 20
der titel der ausarbeitung lautet ein
kranz für wilson
aber diese lage hier bei mir
ich schaue schon etwas zu lesen aus aber
wer sie anschließend einsehen möchte
steht sie natürlich gerne zur verfügung
und auch das bild mit dieser darstellung
die ich jetzt kurz referieren darf
können sie dann auch im original hier in
der zeitung sich anschauen
aus dem genannten artikel von professor
manfred rauchensteiner zitat unter den
deutschsprachigen kärntner zeigte sich
zunehmend optimismus italiens vertreter
in der plebiszit kommission dagegen
glaubte die deutsch kärntner hätten
keine chance auf dem bild mit einer
straßenszene aus klagenfurt
ich hab das ihnen zeigt in der
samstagsausgabe der presse vom dritten
oktober ist ein transparent zu sehen mit
der aufschrift ich bemühe mich das so zu
zitieren wie es niedergeschrieben ist
aber kann das natürlich nicht im
kärntner dialekt wiedergeben der
aufschrift auf diesem transparent lautet
bei uns ist die freiheit die ruhe und
das glück reserven ist der kerker sand
lugen und zwar so ein transparent in
klagenfurt zur zeit der kärntner
volksabstimmung während der kärntner
volksabstimmung zu bemerken ist noch was
am pessimistischsten die kärntner
volksabstimmung betreffend die
österreichische regierung war ich
zitiere rauchensteiner weiter sie tat es
geschah im september 1995
der kärntner landeshauptmann christof
zernatto und mitglieder des
geschichtsvereins natürlich auch unsere
heutige vortragende reisten nach
washington und legten in der national
cathedral am grab des amerikanischen
präsidenten woodrow wilson einen kranz
nieder
was so spontan und wohl auch für die
amerikaner überraschend geschah hatte
einen guten grund
es sollte geehrt werden hatte er doch
maßgeblich dazu beigetragen dass es 1920
in kärnten eine volksabstimmung gab das
plebiszit sicherte den verbleib des
südlichen kärnten österreich in
slowenien sah man wohl keinen grund ist
der kärntner delegation gleichzutun
im umkehrschluss wäre ja zu
argumentieren gewesen wilson sei schuld
daran gewesen dass slowenien nicht
zumindest bis zum wörthersee und an die
burg reichte das kaffeesudlesen
wahlausgang betreffend hielt an bis zum
10 oktober dann lag das endergebnis vor
knapp 60 prozent der
abstimmungsberechtigten hatten bei einer
weit über 90 prozent liegenden
wahlbeteiligung für österreich bestimmt
slowenien war es ein schock für
österreich grund zur freude und der
dankbarkeit der analyse des
wahlverhaltens auch damals gab es schon
entsprechende analysen stellte sich
heraus dass vor allem die slowenischen
bauern ein klares pro österreichisches
votum abgegeben hatten
während industriell geprägte hre orte in
der südlichen umgebung von klagenfurt
aber auch die büchsenmacher werkstatt
büchsenmacher stadt ferlach mehrheitlich
für den anschluss von überschlagen
gestimmt hatten
zitat ende das abstimmungsergebnis in
ferlach betreffend gibt es in der
tageszeitung die presse vom siebenten
oktober 2020 eine berichtigung als
leserbrief durch privatdozent dr alfred
ogris ehemaliger direktor des kärntner
landesarchivs wonach verlag bei der
volksabstimmung mit 72,5 prozent
natürlich mehrheitlich für österreich
bestimmt hat alles bis zum 10 oktober im
verlauf und seine konsequenzen wird uns
nunmehr vor professor dr claudia fries
er feld nahe bringen
professor ich darf sie ans rednerpult
bieten
im rassigen dankeschön für die
einleitung sehr schmeichelhaft wegen der
wegen der bezeichnung als ist so die
historikerin kärntens sehr gesprächig
hoffe ich werde ihren erwartungen
gerecht werden können
meine herren liebe marie vell nach dem
ende des ersten weltkriegs trafen sich
ab jänner 1919 in paris die siegermächte
allen voran die großen vier usa
großbritannien frankreich italien
sie entschieden über die neuordnung
europas reiche waren zerfallen es gab
eine unzahl von grenzen zu regeln vom
bosporus bis dänemark
man wollte eine neue eine demokratische
art des schließens der ruf nach
selbstbestimmung der völker wie in der
amerikanische präsident woodrow wilson
geprägt hatte war allgegenwärtig erlebte
auch die idee der volksabstimmung eine
blütezeit und vielen seiten auch von
wien wurde die forderung nach
plebisziten an die konferenz
herangetragen
trotzdem haben die alliierten friedens
macher dieses instrument äußerst sparsam
eingesetzt
volksabstimmungen waren langwierig und
kostspielig schnelle entscheidungen am
grünen tisch angesichts des fonds an
problemen zielführende auch jedes
funktionierende väter complete das
schaffen vollzogener tatsachen vor ort
wurde akzeptiert
in den friedensverträgen zwischen
alliierten mittelmächten schienen nur
fünf plebiszite auf vier im vertrag von
versailles mit dem deutschen reich und
eine einzige die kärntner im
staatsvertrag von sascha mal mit
österreich eine volksabstimmung also für
die von deutschen bewohnte
gegen monarchie gebiete in böhmen mähren
und schlesien keine für die
untersteiermark keine für südtirol
warum dann eine für kärnten das
strittige klagenfurter becken so die
gängige bezeichnung bei den pariser
verhandlungen war weder politisch noch
wirtschaftlich wichtig dass die causa
kärnten in paris dennoch zu einem
sonderfall wurde zu einem der
wichtigsten männer des spiels wie eine
völkerbund experten später sagte all das
hatte drei anschiebe als ausgangspunkt
den kärntner abwehr willen das
glückliche timing und die amerikanische
miles mission nach ende des ersten
weltkriegs standen sich in kärnten zwei
nachfolgestaaten der zerbrochenen
habsburger monarchie als kontrahenten
gegenüber deutsch österreich und der
neue sitz slawische staat sas
jugoslawien letzterer beanspruchte
kärntner gebiet wegen der hier lebenden
slowenen die slowenische hauptstadt
laibach reagierte blitzschnell politisch
und militärisch in klagenfurt wurde noch
vor kriegsende ein slowenischer volksrat
eingeschätzt als sektion des laibacher
rösrather blitzartiger folgte auch die
militärische besetzung von kärntner
gebiet durch syrische truppen ab siebten
november 1918
es galt vollzogene tatsachen zu schaffen
bevor die friedenskonferenz im jänner
1919 begann der ehemalige kassier rudolf
meister hatte es in marburg vorgemacht
widerstand hier blieb schwach die
friedenskonferenz hat später die
besetzung akzeptiert und die
untersteiermark dem sas staat
zugesprochen
in kärnten sollte es auch so laufen mit
den deutschen werden wir leichter
spiel haben ist es in der klagenfurter
slowenischen zeitung mehr so
siegessicher die laibacher seite war so
blockiert war die kern der politik in
diesen ersten nachkriegs sagen aber man
folgte dem demokratischen weg am 11
november 1918 konstituiert sich in
klagenfurt das land kärnten tritt der
republik deutsch österreich bei und gibt
sich eine provisorische verfassung darin
ist festgehalten dass die kärntner
slowenen aufgrund des
selbstbestimmungsrechtes selbst über
ihre zukünftige staatliche zugehörigkeit
entscheiden sollen
die vorgehensweise festzusetzen das
überließ man der friedenskonferenz in
paris
bis dahin muss oder verfassungstext
weiter sollte das land kärnten das ganze
ehemalige kronland verwalten
die realität sah anders aus es mitte
dezember 1918 war ganz südkärnten
inklusive völkermarkt nur lichter brauch
sitze habe ich besetzt
die kärntner politische führung wurde es
eng
die volks wer das berufsheer der
republik war erst im aufbau begriffen
anfang dezember 1918 hatte der
landesbudgets habe oberstleutnant bürger
erst rund 600 mann zur verfügung
es war in dieser situation ein sehr
mutiger schritt als der kärntner landtag
am 5 dezember 1918 den militärischen
widerstand beschloss einstimmig sogar
mit den stimmen des soldaten rates im
entschluss folgte zunächst folgten
zunächst keine taten im dezember 1918
musste die kärntner politik sogar
ernsthaft überlegen gewisse teile
zyperns zu opfern eine politik des
machbaren war gefragt die parole frei
und ungeteilt nicht realistisch an der
wendepunkt grafenstein
15km vor klagenfurt erster militärische
erfolg und auftakt des abwehrkampfes in
den ersten zwei jener wochen 1919 konnte
schließlich die hälfte des slawischen
kopierten südkärnten durch volkswahl
verbände und freiwillige alarm kompanien
zurückerobert werden
das ist binnen 36 stunden gelang das
rosental zurückzugewinnen bezeichnete
der amerikanische offizier schirmen
miles später als praktiziertes
selbstbestimmungsrechtes leuten mainz
mitglied einer us-studie kommission in
österreich pflichtete bei den
waffenstillstandsverhandlungen nach den
jänner kämpfen er war es beobachter im
land dürfte keinesfalls aktiv eingreifen
da tat es trotzdem
um weitere kämpfe zu verhindern es
folgte eine bekannte miles mission vier
amerikaner bereisten neun tage lang
südkärnten und verfassten anschließend
detaillierte berichte über ihre
erfahrungen ja mehrheitlich erstelltes
resümee kärnten ist eine geografische
und wirtschaftliche einheit es soll
nicht geteilt weil werden auch weil die
hier lebenden menschen selbst jene
slowenischer nationalität dies nicht
wollen
carvalho sollen grenze seinem das gebiet
österreich bleiben
eine intervention nach arzt der mars
mission hat es während der ganzen
friedenskonferenz nie mehr gegeben
derartige einseitige einmischungen
wurden von den alliierten siegermächten
strikt untersagt die meist berichte
dürften nicht publik gemacht werden in
kärnten mit kannte man ihr ergebnis
nicht aber sie waren im besitz der
amerikanischen für installation
handfeste
authentisches material niemand hatte
vergleichbares die us diplomaten konnten
damit punkten
das timing war perfekt mit den meist
berichten änderte sich die sichtweise
auf die frage des klagenfurter beckens
noch bevor die verhandlungen in paris
begonnen
vorher waren die alliierten diplomaten
und experten davon ausgegangen dass
gerechte grenzen wie sie von den neuen
nationalstaaten gewünscht wurden
sprachgrenzen waren grenzen die
strittige gebiete nach sprachlichen
ethnischen kriterien teilte die mission
hatte aber in kärnten zu ihrem großem
erstaunen festgestellt dass es hier
slowenen gab die keine jugoslawen sein
wollten sondern lieber mit ihren
deutschsprachigen nachbarn in der alten
heimat blieben auch wenn diese zur
deutsche österreich gehörte damit rückte
das wirtschaftliche argument in den
mittelpunkt klagenfurt als zentraler
markt im die bäuerliche bevölkerung aus
allen teilen des landes besonders auch
aus dem süden zustrebte diese erkenntnis
wog umso schwerer als es die feste
überzeugung der amerikaner war das ohne
gesunde wirtschaft demokratische
entwicklung nicht funktioniert die
bedeutung der miles berichte ist klar
sei es auch dass es ohne die
länderkämpfe in kärnten nicht zur miles
mission gekommen wäre und in den 1970 er
jahren wurde dieser kausale zusammenhang
von der fortschrittlichen wissenschaft
verneint im fünften nichts bewirkt haben
wir die kärntner historiker widerlegten
anfang des heurigen jahres verlautete
plötzlich erneut in einem radiointerview
der abwehrkampf habe keine rolle
gespielt
die amerikaner um oberst leighton
chairman
hätten auch ohne kämpfe ihre berichte
geschrieben
die anfang 1919 in wien stationierte us
studien kommission hat tatsächlich als
vorbereitung auf die friedenskonferenz
viele berichte über die zustände im
ehemaligen österreich umgang geschrieben
von grenzfragen an der adria bis
tschechoslowakei keinem dieser berichte
lag eine untersuchung vor ort zu grunde
keiner spielte später eine rolle bei dem
pariser verhandlungen
es gab nur eine einzige echte
intervention durch eine alliierte macht
während der ganzen konferenz immer als
mission sie kam zustande weil die
amerikaner neue kämpfe in kärnten
verhindern wollten und wesentlich weil
mais die erfolgsaussichten positiv
einschätzten jugoslawen war nach den für
die kärntner seite erfolgreichen jänner
kämpfen in einer position der schwäche
deshalb so schloss mainz hätten sie in
die mission eingewilligt
als kurz danach die grazer regierung mal
versuchte auch in der untersteiermark zu
intervenieren lehnt er ab hier sei
jugoslawien unbehelligt der kurator und
hätte keinen grund sich auf derartiges
einzulassen
auch dies zeigt die bedeutung des
abwehrkampfes am 18
jänner 1919 hatte die pariser
friedenskonferenz begonnen
am 18 februar präsentierte die
jugoslawische friedens delegation dem
plenum unter anderem ihre wunsch
grenzlinie in kärnten sie verlief
nördlich des ganzen klagenfurter bittens
inklusive villach und klagenfurt
österreich hatte als verlierer stadt
keinen zutritt zur konferenz
umso wichtiger waren die meist berichte
anfang april 19 wurde schließlich in
einem gremium alliierte experten
in paris die frage des klagenfurter
becken es zum ersten mal verhandelt die
amerikanischen experten brechen vor und
verlangen unter berufung auf miles die
übergabe des ganzen klagen für diabetes
an österreich die briten wollen aus
ethnisch nationalen gründen wenigstens
eine befragung der bevölkerung man
einigt sich auf die befragung die im
weiteren verlauf der konferenz war blick
sieht lösung wurde ist diese lösung aber
tatsächlich unumstößlich war weiß ein
weiter weg mit vielen hürden auf diesem
weg wurde von sas seite diplomatisch wie
militärisch versucht die volksabstimmung
zu verhindern und eine direkte abtretung
von kärntner gebiet an jugoslawien zu
erreichen bieten und franzosen
unterstützten immer wieder die sitze
argumentation nur der amerikanische
präsident wilson beharrte auf der
volksabstimmung bis zum schluss wird der
ablauf der ereignisse als die auf die
erste für österreich positive
verhandlungsrunde im april 1919 als die
pläne sieht lösung auf kam wollte die
jugoslawische reaktion in form der
militärischen offensive ab 29 april 19
zielrichtung einnahme von klagenfurt
sind mai andauernden kämpfe waren der
höhepunkt des abwehrkampfes völkermarkt
befreit und in erfolg folge ganz gern
bis ins mister trotz der warnung wiens
dass man sich mit völkermarkt begnügen
und die trauer nicht überschreiten soll
hatten diese kämpfe keine negative
auswirkung auf die verhandlungen in
paris wurden vielmehr wie schon die
jener kämpfe als praktiziertes
selbstbestimmungsrecht gesehen
am 20 12 09 10 dann im obersten rat die
entscheidung
oberrad war das höchste gremium der
konferenz bestehend aus den
regierungschefs der vier alliierten
haupt mächte us-präsident müssen der
britische premier george der
französische ministerpräsident
clemenceau und sein italienischer
amtskollege orlando im obersten rat also
wird am 12
mai 1919 die volksabstimmung für kärnten
beschlossen und zwar im ganzen
klagenfurter becken als einheit das
heißt die späteren zwei abstimmungs
zonen gemeinsam
hier gab es ein deutschsprachiges
übergewicht 57 prozent zu 43 prozent
dieses blieb ich sieht konnte
jugoslawien nicht riskieren kärnten
durfte nicht verloren gehen es galt als
wiege der slowenischen staatlichkeit man
musste weiter kämpfen
im obersten rat wurde von sas seite
umgehend ein kompromiss vorgeschlagen
die zwei zonen lösung
der südliche teil des klagenfurter
beckens entsprechend der späteren da
zählen abstimmungs zone also rosendahl
landtag gebiet um völkermarkt sollte
sofort und ohne plebiszit an jugoslawien
fallen auf den nördlichen teil mit
klagenfurt der späteren sonne waren
bereit zu verzichten
jessen blieb unnachgiebig und bestand
auf der volksabstimmung wie gehabt diese
wurde daraufhin am 29 mai 1919 nun zum
zweiten mal beschlossen die
jugoslawische antwort der generalangriff
entlang der ganzen kärntner front ab 29
diesmal war gegenwehr chancenlos
parallel zur militärischen aktion
erhöhten die jugoslawischen diplomaten
in paris abermals den druck auf die
konferenz sie hatten stets zutritt zu
den verhandlungs gremien die
österreichische delegation hingegen mit
staatskanzlei renner an der spitze
wartete seit 14
juni bei den 14 09 10 19 im schloss von
sascha moll paris fast eingesperrt und
völlig isoliert auf die übergabe der
friedens des friedensvertrags entwurfs
am zweiten juni 19 war es soweit
in österreich wird das engagement der
vertragsentwurf übergeben
darin fehlt der abschnitt über die
kärntner volksabstimmung aber im letzten
moment vom französischen premier als
präsident der konferenz aus dem vertrag
entfernt worden
das geschehen im hintergrund mit seinen
geheimen winkelzügen kennt man nicht aus
den offiziellen protokoll wohl aber aus
den spannenden tagebuchaufzeichnungen
des britischen diplomaten hereth
nicholson einige passagen aus diesem
tagebuch sondern erst der juni der tag
vor der vertrags übergabe in österreich
gebucht philipp kommt während ich mich
gerade zum abendessen um ca
er sagt die serben weigerten sich morgen
ist ja mal zu erscheinen und zwar wegen
der artikel über die volksabstimmungen
klagenfurt elendig verschlingen in den
abend es und stürzen dann zur sorge ja
war ein wichtiges mitglied der
jugoslawischen friends delegation ins
positive jugoslawen scheuen offenbar
eine abstimmung in diesem gebiet weil
sie wissen dass sie gegen sie ausfallen
wird
sie behaupten es sei ungerecht ihnen
eine abstimmung aufzuzwingen in gebieten
wo sie keine wollen und sie ihnen in
anderen gebieten zu verweigern wo sie
leidenschaftlich eine fordern den görtz
und gradiska sie wollen wenigstens eine
abstimmung nach gemeinden dann würden
sie morgen kommen
das bedeutet dass man die zustimmung der
drei erlangen müssen tagebuch weiter da
es bereits 31 in der nacht ist
als wir verfolger weg kommen ist das
eine schwierige sache
montag 2 juni zu hause in aller frühe
nieto gehwege lloyd george dazu
einzuwilligen dass die klang vor der
abstimmung nach gemeinden vollzogen
werden soll
oder wenigstens nicht als einheit dann
weiter zu präsident wurzeln der
ausgegangen ist warte bis 11.15 zu
welchem zeitpunkt sie alle in astrachan
müssen bekomme hörst zu fassen und
schärfe in genau 1 was er zu tun hat
wenn er wissens zustimmung nicht mehr
rechtzeitig bekommen muss bekommt muss
die verfügung über das klang für der
becken aus dem vertrag heraus gerissen
werden bevor der vertrag den
österreichern übergeben wird
hörst begibt sie nach samoa und fängt
präsident wilson auf der treppe ab
präsident wir sind nicht schlechter
laune daher eine reifenpanne gehabt man
sich verspätet hat er weigert sich
irgendetwas zu ändern
zum glück sieht clemenceau worum es geht
und reißt den klagenfurt abschnitt aus
dem vertrag heraus wie vorher doch
trainer überreicht wird soweit ist alles
gut und wir haben schon wort gehalten er
hat uns auch wort gehalten und war mit
seiner ganzen delegation zur stelle aber
um ein haar wäre es schiefgegangen
tagebucheintragungen ende
die österreicher waren konsterniert an
jenem zweiten juni in paris erst am
vierten juni die erleichterung
es sollte doch eine volksabstimmung
geben aber das rad hatte sich schon
weiter gedreht weil sie den puls hat der
mittlerweile der zwei zonen lösung
zugestimmt beharrte aber auf der
volksabstimmung jetzt eben in getrennten
wahlgängen am vierten juni wird das
kärntner blieb ich sie zum dritten mal
beschlossen die bedingungen für
österreich waren härter geworden
in der südlichen zone wo zuerst
abgestimmt werden sollte
war die bevölkerung zu 70 zu wenig
sprache
es kam noch härter am 06 09 10 19 uhr
die klagenfurt dazu ein großer teil des
abstimmungsgebot von sas militär
okkupiert was unruhe und angst
verursachte das war die passivität zu
der man in kärnten damals verurteilt war
alle steckte fest abwehrkampf verloren
klagenfurt besetzt
auf der pariser konferenz war die
volksabstimmung beschlossen aber ob die
jungs laden je das land verlassen würden
und ein plebiszit abgehalten werden
konnte schien unsicher das vertrauen der
kärntner betroffenen in die
durchschlagskraft der alliierten hielt
sich in grenzen
befehle aus paris aus libyen die truppen
aus dem klagenfurter becken abzuziehen
waren mehrmals unbeachtet geblieben
in dieser schwierigen phase beginnt fiel
auf eine wichtige rolle zu spielen
die alliierte macht italien mischt sich
direkt ein
ihr hauptinteresse gilt im
eisenbahnknoten villach und dass dieser
nicht von sie zwischen truppen besetzt
wird zwischen italien und jugoslawien
eskalierte damals der konflikt über die
grenzen in istrien und dalmatien mann
stand sich feindlich gegenüber er sitze
habe ich besetztes vielleicht hätte
dieses zugs verbindung von italien über
villach richtung norden empfindlich
gestört
das musste verhindert werden in dieser
situation nicht general de bono
kommandeur des im kanaltal stehen und 22
aus freier hand zum eingreifen
am 12 juni 19 besetzen italienische
truppen rund 30.000 mann mit 7000
pferden und diversen kriegsgerät die
eisenbahnstrecke viele kirchen sankt
veit bislang aus dorf general verlegte
sein kommando von girona nach vieler ins
parkhotel überall entlang der
bahnstrecke war italienisches militär
stationiert
am dichtesten fehler für die kärntner
politik war die anwesenheit der
italiener im sommer 19 19 eine
beruhigung auf der pariser konferenz wo
experten gerade die genauen
durchführungsbestimmungen für das
kärntner plebiszit ausarbeiteten wird
die neue lage jedoch zu einem umdenken
es schien nicht mehr opportun
evakuierung des klagenfurter beckens zu
verlangen ein geräumtes gebiet bedeutete
möglicherweise neue unruhen
es stand zu befürchten dass italien in
das vakuum vorstieß dem den abzug der
syrischen truppen zu erzwingen wurde
schließlich verworfen
für die durchführung des plebiszits fand
die friedenskonferenz eine neue lösung
ursprünglich hatte man vorgehabt das
abstimmungs gebiet von einer neutralen
macht und der aufsicht des völkerbundes
verwalten zu lassen
das war die regelung wie sie auch für
die volksabstimmungen im vertrag von der
seite
die nun für kärnten getroffene neue
lösung bedeutete eine weitere
verschärfung
es wurde entschieden dass die südliche
zone a dort waren 10 oktober 1920
abgestimmt wurde
bis zur abstimmung jugoslawisch besetzt
und verwaltet werden sollte die
kleineren örtliche zone b mit klagenfurt
von österreich als der österreicher klar
war das nicht eine neutrale macht
sondern jugoslawien bis zum baby sieht
die verwaltung der südlichen zone über
haben sollte war der schock groß
die abstimmung wird unter dem druck der
sas jedenfalls für uns elend aus finden
ausfallen so und ähnlich artikuliert sie
sich die mutlosigkeit der kärntner
führung
zum glück wurde die kärntner man macht
ja auch ab änderungsvorschläge also eine
zone weise abwertung das wurde zum glück
von der konferenz in paris nicht
angenommen wenn es angenommen worden
wäre
kärnten südlich darauf am 10 oktober
verloren gegangen
dort war nämlich 312 stimmen überhang
für die sas seite staatsvertrag kann
sich schon mal wurde wurde am zehnten
september 19 unterzeichnet es folgte das
mehr als einjährige warten auf die
volksabstimmung bis alle verträge
ratifiziert waren musste man warten
die teilung des landes so eine art zone
b waren durch eine demarkationslinie
getrennt hermetisch geschlossen wie es
damals immer in den quellen heißt also
niemand durfte durch die jugoslawische
seite die ja den südteil die südliche
zone besetzte wollte damit klagenfurt
schaden als wirtschaftsstandort wollte
überhaupt verschiedene dinge damit
bewirken das ist völlig daneben gegangen
denn in kärnten in der zone a hat man
gemerkt was es bedeutet wenn das land
geteilt ist wenn die märkte in villach
unter der markt in klagenfurt für die
bäuerliche bevölkerung mit ihren
produkten wegfällt usw also viele dinge
haben da auf die stimmung geschlagen und
dazu kam dann ein großartiger wirklich
großartiger grandioser kampf wo eine
propagandaschlacht die vonseiten
österreichs damals geführt wurde zuerst
mit unter schwierigsten bedingungen
unter dieser demarkationslinie durch
jeder musste damit rechnen
standrechtlich oder halt zumindest
erschossen zu werden wenn er das gesagt
hat also es waren schwierige bedingungen
aber man hat es gewagt und man hat das
durchgeführt man hat ein netz von
leuten auf der anderen seite aufgebaut
und hat die besten köpfe im land also
künstler und an der spitze stand
überhaupt der führende literat im land
bergkönig alle wie hartmann eingesetzt
um einen eine großartige
propagandaschlacht zu führen also es hat
auch mit dazu geführt dass die stimmung
sich gedreht hat war man am anfang auf
österreichischer seite also der meinung
das kann man nicht gewinnen diese
abstimmung ist unmöglich zu gewinnen
dann hat sich das langsam gedreht und im
juli an als in 20 ist nun von belgrad an
wien das angebot einer zone weisen aus
als zonen weisen auswertung des
abstimmungsergebnisses gekommen und da
generali jurist darauf schon eingegangen
beim rauchen ständer zitieren der
staatskanzlei renner fährt nach sankt
veit zum treffen mit der kärntner
regierung diese lehnt jetzt ab was sie
im sommer zuvor selbst angestrebt hatte
man hofft damals bereits auf 60 prozent
der stimmen
die kärntner waren mit ihrer zuversicht
ziemlich allein
es ist renner hoch anzurechnen dass er
trotz eigene skepsis der kärntner
regierung vertraute skeptisch war der
präsident der installierten plebiszit
kommission die ende juli endlich nach so
vielen monaten ihre arbeit in kärnten
aufnahmen er bezweifelte der engländer
sagte beck ob es möglich sein einem
gebiet das unter der verwaltung einer
der beiden seiten war ein faires
plebiszit überhaupt durchzuführen
es war eine sieht eine herausforderung
diese situation aber ich glaube es war
auch eine chance dieses schwierige
bedingungen denn versuche die
volksabstimmung zu vereiteln
durch unruhen die man angezettelt hat
paris war das sehr schnell und hat
gesagt also gut dass in unruhen keine
volksabstimmung wird teilen
also diese schwierigen bedingungen haben
es verhindert glaube ich dass man
versucht hat die volksabstimmung zu
vereiteln von beiden seiten
die abstimmung wurde regulär
durchgeführt und der präsident der
plebiszit kommission der schon zitierte
engländer beck den grund dafür darin
gesehen dass beide seiten bis zum
schluss an den sieg geglaubt haben dass
volksabstimmung ergeben ist 59 prozent
für österreich war hieb und stichfest
und wurde als gemeinsame willensäußerung
deutschen zu wenig sprechen der kärntner
auch von den 41 prozent die für sas
gestimmt hatten zur kenntnis genommen
nur zweimal durch eine
nationalsozialistische und eine
kommunistische diktatur wurde die grenz
lösung von 1920 missachtet 100 jahre
danach blicken wir mit freude und
dankbarkeit auf die demokratische
entscheidung vom 10
oktober 1920 dankeschön
[Musik]
vielen dank frau professor für ihre
packenden ausführungen
ich möchte mich auch ganz besonders
bedanken dass sie auch noch für eine
diskussion zur verfügung stehen möchte
mich auch bei sofort schmiedel herzlich
bedanken der auch im vorstand der
stratec angehört dass er sich bereit
erklärt hat die diskussion zu moderieren
ich möchte vielleicht nur mit einer
bemerkung selbst beginnen
ich persönlich war immer der meinung
dass es heiß staat bedeutet start des
serben kroaten und slowenen
das ist aber ein irrtum denn die
republik jugoslawien sollte von
slowenien kroatien und serbien gebildet
werden
das haben wir selber was sofort
abgedreht und haben erklärt dass
jugoslawien ein königreich wird unter
könig peter dem ersten und haben gesagt
es heißt es bleibt der gleiche aber
lässt er die das königreich der serben
kroaten und slowenen und die slowenen
waren einfach mal dritte und letzte
ursprünglich waren sie an erster stelle
das war für mich neu und hat gewisser
weise ein bild der situation bestärkt
und bestätigt europa darf ich bitten die
diskussionsleitung zu übernehmen
[Musik]
interessanten vortrag dann glaube ich
einen wirklich guten und wichtigen
überblick gegeben hat als
diskussionsleitung bitten zunächst
einmal die frage in die carola bedingt
ein bisschen reduzierte runde
obe es unmittelbare frage bemerken
gibt generalstabs general meisten bitte
mit mikrofon weil sonst nicht in der
übertragung verständlich und dank noch
einmal im vortrag eine frage
das hat sich ja fast über 100 jahre dann
durchgezogen wurden damals auch schon
rechte der minderheit diskutiert oder
festgelegt weniger also nicht so
dezidiert mandats für minderheitenrechte
im auf den verträgen auch festgelegt
aber das war nicht ein thema wie so sehr
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
auch ich möchte mich bedanken ich will
bevor ich die frage schnell fahren
kommen wir vielleicht noch einmal auf
die suche nach dem zweiten weltkrieg ein
korrektur des vorganges zwanzigster
[Musik]
hinzukriegen
also stelle ich sie gleich und waren
haben damit beispiele dafür dass der
stuhl
ich war in einem kongress von laien in
der katholischen kirche in rom und dann
musste man einen immer sein und mehr
zugeteilte partner bei jugoslawischer
priester
er gehört hat dass sie auch sofort seine
frage weiter genau nach 45 gelaufen ist
nämlich dass österreich 50 millionen
dollar im steilen geteilt habe damit er
habe
dann sozusagen heute drängt unter ist
alles so bliebe dass österreich in den
grenzen von 1937 wieder hergestellt
würde
es hat also nicht ihre brennen jemand
gesagt oder immerhin sowie der elite das
für beide strömungen anscheinend immer
noch vorher steht im untergrund schweben
ist das ehepaar kann man dass ich das
schon aus dem weg geschafft
also habe ich noch nie gehört dass so
derartige anschuldigungen aber also es
ist ja ziemlich gut gearbeitet wie es
unserem staatsvertrag gekommen ist und
wie das mittel an mit den forderungen
von seiten jugoslawiens wieder auf
kärnten bestellt war
und wie die drei west-alliierten ja
immer der meinung waren es sollen
österreich solle in den grenzen von 1937
wieder hergestellt werden und die tor
war natürlich anderer meinung und salem
hat ihn zuerst unterstützt aber dann 48
bruchsal in quito dann ist es relativ
schnell gegangen die mir 49 war dann
endgültig fixiert dass österreich so
also dass die zahl der starts parks oder
die grenzen so bleiben wie sie mir 19 37
war bis zum staatsvertrag dazu noch
einige zeit gedauert
noch kurz etwas hin geantwortet aber
dann war unsere gesprächsbasis beendet
ich habe sie müssen zur bitte zur
kenntnis nehmen zwei punkte erstens
österreich hat niemand 50 millionen
dollar zur verfügung gestellt um die
stalin hinzugeben und zweitens in
österreich war niemand so blöd dass er
für ein international verbrieftes recht
dass unsere grenzen wieder wie in 1997
hergestellt werden 50 millionen hergeben
hätte selbst wenn wir sie gehabt hätten
daraufhin war unsere freundschaft
beendet ja was zecher hatte eine frage
aber fest ich nach vielleicht wieder
zurückführen in der zeit da der
abstimmung und in die situation hinein
führen
nachdem überreichung des staatsvertrages
wir wissen es gab dann den tänzen der
einiger kronländer sich von der republik
österreich loszulösen im sinne von
anschlüsse an die schweiz vor handwerk
auch in tirol gab es überlegungen und
dasselbe gilt auch für kärnten usa
kurzfristig überlegungen waren einen
freistaat kärnten zu bieten wenn sie
dazu etwas sagen ja das war in der
verzweifelte ende 1918 wie es also ich
hab das erzählte meine vortrag wie das
also für kern ist er schlecht gestanden
ist und anfang des jahres 1919 das war
eine sehr kurzfristige etappe von
feldern ausgehend hat man gefunden wenn
man jetzt kärnten verselbstständigt zu
quasi dann könnte man also hier slowenen
und deutsch so wenig schweigen
deutschsprachige innerhalb des landes
belassen und und das müsste müsste diese
diskussion um abspaltung oder und
grenzziehung überhaupt unterbleiben
also das war die idee kärnten den
kärntnern wir wollen weder nach nach
nach laibach oder nachbarn noch nach
wien kärnten soll eine einheit bleiben
nämlich alle kärntner slowenischen und
die und die deutschen
das war eine kurzfristige idee die dann
aber eingeschlafen ist natürlich nur
einen wurf machen
ich hätte es vielleicht schon sagen
sollen sagt aber jetzt für unsere gäste
an den streaming geräten besteht
natürlich die möglichkeit sich in die
diskussion einzuschalten
schreiben sie uns ihre fragen die sie
haben und diese werden nach möglichkeit
dann von meinem geschäftsführenden
vorstand an das podium gestellt und
hoffentlich auch beantwortet also bitte
schreiben sie uns ihre fragen und
mischen sie sich in die diskussion ein
danke
lingen
gefragt
na ja er hatte er hat es ja auch nicht
sehr leicht gehabt und es gab viel
gegenargumente gegen seine seine ideen
des friedens marktes und der hat auch
nicht immer so agiert wie er seinem
selbstbestimmungsrecht dass er ihr
bruder propagiert hat entsprochen als
wie zb südtirol
da war ja da würde man im jahr kein
denkmal setzen
zum unterschied von kärnten wo wir an
seinem grab waren und ein kranz
niedergelegt haben aber ich glaube dass
es so gelaufen ist müssen hatte diese
wirklich farbe haften mainz berichte die
detailliert waren die dann die gut waren
die wirklich man hat zwar die mission
auch kritisiert und hat gesagt zu sein
also amerikaner gewesen naive amerikaner
die von ethnografischen fragen überhaupt
keine ahnung hat und sie sind also haben
also eher berichte gestellt aber
tatsächlich hat sie hat die
volksabstimmung selbst dann gezeigt dass
genau dieses bild das die mission
gemacht hat er sich gemacht hat und in
ihren berichten beschrieben hat dass es
genau so ausgegangen ist also er hatte
diese berichte und er hatte ein team
er hat ja die fand er hatte franzosen
und briten und italiener auf der anderen
seite gegen sich manchmal gegen sich
manchmal im prinzip hat er bereits auf
diesen auf diesen erkenntnissen die nur
er so gut hatte und das war für kernen
eine riesige chance erstes dass es
überhaupt zu dieser mais mission
gekommen ist dass diese berichte
vorgelegen sind dass der westen sich
eingeschossen hat auf diese berichte der
spanier die berichte seien
leute niemand hatte was vergleichbares
niemand hat es so was at authentisches
und gutes und da konnte er punkten und
das hat er auch und es ist erstaunlich
diese kleine kärntner frage bis 90 ich
glaube insgesamt an die bild acht bis
zehnmal im obersten rat zu dieser zu
dieser frage gemeldet es gibt sogar ein
bild und es gibt sogar beschreibungen
wie er sich mit der karte am boden hin
dass hier rundherum die anderen der
gottes großen des obersten rats die
großen vier und jeder nachzeichnet den
kern wo die grenze verlaufen soll
und immer wieder mit diesen argumenten
aus den meist berichten argumentiert da
hatte sich festgefahren an diesen dingen
und er ist damit durchgekommen und hat
das war für ihn ja auch erfolgreich und
vielleicht ist ja auch damit
durchgekommen es ist zwar von britischer
und französischer seite immer wieder
gegenwind gekommen auch von
italienischer seite wenn es um die
eisenbahn gegangen ist ist auch
innerhalb des amerikanischen lagers gab
es leute die gesagt es gebe doch den
jugoslawen in kärnten endlich ein
bisschen von dem was sie wollen dann
wären sie in dalmatien und in istrien
nachgeben aber nein der wilson wagner
stur
es hat sogar ein renommierter historiker
als alter historiker aus slowenien
grafenauer prograf vernahmen bekannter
name er hat gesagt dass diese sturheit
vom wissen der wohl darauf
zurückzuführen sei dass damals sich
schon die ersten auswirkungen seiner
späteren psychischen krankheit gezeigt
haben aber nein
george oder wieder ein anderer von den
von den diplomaten hat gesagt wissen
hätte sich also glasklar geäußert zu
kärnten ganz princeton-professor
rechtsprofessorin der
die universität princeton ganz klar dass
sich geäußert und hat seine
vorstellungen für kärnten dargelegt also
eher das war sein thema
und der hat sich durchgesetzt und
vielleicht auch deshalb weil doch kern
nicht so wichtig war dass die engländer
und oder die briten und die franzosen
also wirklich ganz auf stur geschaltet
hätten die nächste frage kommt von
unserem hausherren general athar
südkorea zankl sehr geehrte frau
professor heute gibt es nach jeder noch
jedem freigang und nach jedem nachher
der volksabstimmung ganz klar
wählerstromanalyse und auch konkrete
aussagen und erklärungen er wofür
gestimmt hat und warum liegen
forschungsergebnisse dezidiert vor wie
das zeit zu dieser zeit neun zu 1929
konkret zur volksabstimmung ist gelegt
wurde
ja ja wofür bestimmt hat und in welchem
prozentsatz und warum
ja da gibt es sehr gute arbeiten darüber
also nicht die recht wählerstromanalyse
die heutzutage moderne aber sehr gute
arbeiten die das sehr plausibel darlegen
es war die entscheidung
es haben 10.000 stimmen das weiß man
schon seit gut deshalb beginn der zeit
geschichtsforschung in kärnten ungefähr
10.000 jetzt sagt man vielleicht noch
ein paar mehr slowenischsprachige der
leute aus dieser zone a die am 10
oktober abgestimmt hat für österreich
bestimmt und zwar waren dass die leute
die schon von von ihren
von anderen als nimmt schuhe als deutsch
thümler quasi schlecht gemacht wurden
die haben also für österreich gestimmt
und was die wirtschaft an land so war es
doch so dass die bäuerliche bevölkerung
also die wird ja was die wirtschaft
anlagen zu kann man sagen dass zum
beispiel weil es dem das thema fehler
früher angeschnitten worden ist also
verleihen ferner wurden waffen erzeugt
und fehler war eine deutsche stadt eine
deutschsprachige stadt aber natürlich
haben wir einige leute einige leute wie
ich die grafik erzeugt haben für
überschlagen gestimmt jugoslawien war
eine militär monarchie man konnte damit
rechnen dass man waffen exportiert also
solche analysen sind da gekommen sind
ganz genau ist und ich kann das jetzt
nicht so genau sagen aber auch zb in
einem gebiet in feistritz im rosental da
gab es leute die über die grenzen in
jesenice in aßling in den in der firma
dort gearbeitet haben die haben
vielleicht auch sich gedacht wes brot
ich ess des lied ich sing
sie haben dann auch eher für jugoslawien
gestimmt oder es hat auch adelige
gegeben die große besitzungen jenseits
der grenze hatten die sollen dann auch
für jugoslawien gestimmt haben also
solche dinge wirtschaftlicher natur sind
passiert eine wichtige rolle hat die
sozialdemokratie gespielt denn die
sozialdemokratie war in diesem südlichen
kärnten in der zone a was das eigentlich
eine bäuerliche bevölkerung im
wesentlichen war sehr stark denn bei uns
gibt es immer die weichen viele
weichenden bauernsöhne die natürlich
dann nicht bauern waren sondern in als
in verschiedenen untergeordneten
positionen in der landwirtschaft tätig
waren und sie war ich sehr stark
sozialdemokratisch
auch organisiert und die
sozialdemokratie war für deutsche
österreich eingestellt denn alles was
deutsch war fortschritt all das was
klerikal war wie die meisten auf der
anderen seite klerikal das war natürlich
nicht ihr ding also wenn man
sozialdemokrat war dann war man für die
österreich deutsch österreichischen
seite
das hat auch eine wesentliche rolle
gespielt da gibt es noch viele kleine
dinge die da an zusagen werden dafür
dann hören wir schreiben jetzt bieten
eine publikums anfrage einzubringen
ich bedanke mich in diesem zusammenhang
auch bei unserem live publikum für die
erste frage die gesteigerte inhaltlich
auch zum thema passt aber konkret ist es
wahr dass in wiener regiment am kärntner
abwehrkampf mit beteiligt war
nein es waren verschiedene wege meint
auch es war ja auch franz jonas mit
dabei in kärnten als abwehrkämpfer ja
die sind eingesetzt worden
[Musik]
teilweise sind sie aber damit gleich
wieder das war zur zeit des zweiten
teils des abwehrkampfes der ende april
begonnen hat bis anfang mai wieder an
die kärntner sich entschlossen haben
über die über die drau grenze darüber zu
gehen und also ganz gern und zurück zu
erobern was von wien nicht goutiert
wurde nicht gut geheißen wurde
da konnten also diese teilweise diese
diese volks wer soldaten aus den
österreichischen gebieten die konnten da
nicht mitmachen und sind dann auch nicht
gebraucht worden aber im prinzip haben
es zum beispiel die tiroler einheit
sehr gut gekämpft am rosenbach tunnel
das weiß man also es war österreich hat
immer versucht obwohl in kärnten sehr
oft die meinung unterschiedlich war aber
österreich hat schon versucht österreich
kärnten in dieser frage militärisch
diplomatisch auch wirtschaftlich
finanziell zu unterstützen und auch mit
militärischer unterstützung zu schicken
eine zweite frage die zwar inhaltlich
nicht direkt zum abwehrkampf gehört
beziehungen zur volksabstimmung aber zum
thema heute wollen wir diese beantworten
es zieht sich die frage bis in die
heutige zeit um zwei leute diese was ist
der tatsächliche grund das bis heute die
rechte der deutschsprachigen minderheit
in slowenien und slowenien nicht
anerkannt worden ist
das wird ja vielleicht jetzt ins rollen
kommen das ist eine lange an sache die
es sind die italiener und die
italienische minderheit ist anerkannt
und die die ungarische minderheit in
bremen ebenfalls die deutsche minderheit
nicht aber jetzt laufen durch glaube ich
ganz gut
also es beginnt zu laufen das vielleicht
dieses thema auch einen guten abschluss
findet vielleicht dazu einwerfen dass
bei der festveranstaltung am vergangenen
samstag im klagenfurter landhaus jahr
der landeshauptmann von kärnten sehr
nachdrücklich glaube ich in anwesenheit
der beiden staatsoberhäupter österreichs
und sloweniens dieses thema angesprochen
hat und gebeten hat man möge sich auch
der frage der minderheitenrechte
der österreicher alte österreicher in
slowenien zuwenden also ich kann das nur
bestätigen und hoffe sehr dass da etwas
in gang kommt ja sehr gute stimmung vor
der wahl beschrieben die stimmung dann
nach der wahl nämlich einerseits immer
noch 40 prozent dafür gestimmt nach der
islamischen republik zurückzukehren so
die interne stimmung und wie war die
reaktion der sas darauf dass ganz
einfach heutzutage wenn bei solchen
abstimmungen wird wird in frage gestellt
ist alles richtig abgelaufen und
dergleichen
wie kann man so wie ich die stimmung
danach es war für für die islamische
seite sicherlich ein schock
man hat auch reagiert und ist hat wieder
so quasi ist wieder zu einer gewissen
besetzung geschritten aber das war eine
kurze etappe und im november war dann
alles vorbei man hat das anerkannt und
das ganze war geregelt
am 13 oktober hat man schon in
klagenfurt das ergebnis präsentiert und
also das mit später dann nie mehr
wirklich in frage gestellt worden
mit ausnahme zur zeit des
nationalsozialismus wo man diese grenzen
eben nicht mehr respektiert hat sondern
darüber hinaus gegangen ist und später
an tito ist hat ja wieder das nicht
respektiert sondern ist auch nach
kärnten gekommen hat bis anfang des 19
dann auch gerne gebiet wieder besetzt
die interne stimmung wenn man natürlich
sehr froh und man hat ja vorher schon
das wird immer wieder thematisiert dass
die kern der landesregierung vor der
abstimmung so quasi gesagt hat man wir
werden wenn er uns welt werden wir
natürlich schauen dass alle rechte und
freiheiten gesichert sind und dass sie
ihre sprache verwenden könnte und so
weiter
ob das dann auch so viele 41 gegolten
hat die nicht für österreich gestimmt
haben sondern für jugoslawien das ist
die frage
das wird natürlich immer wieder als
großer vorwurf in den raum gestellt dass
nachher nicht so gehandelt wurde
man hat damals das waren zeiten des
nationalismus und man hat eigentlich
sich vorgestellt dass man die leute die
nicht österreich gestimmt hatten dass
man die für österreich gewinnen muss und
da sind natürlich dinge passiert sind
einige es waren ja keine keine wilden
zeiten sondern man hat ja mit vehemenz
seine standpunkte vertreten und da waren
sehr viel einige geistliche darunter es
waren andere leute darunter die sind
teils freiwillig haben sie das land
verlassen kärnten nämlich oder das sind
sie auch ausgewiesen worden
aber das ja das war aus der zeit zu
verstehen
wenn jetzt noch zwei fragen herr
brigadier und dann hoffe dass man
bis 8
nein das wird nicht vorgekommen bitte
das mikrofon gleich weitergeben und so
für entspannung
neulich wollte nur noch ganz kärnten
abwehrkampf
[Musik]
österreich regionen
wenn wir jetzt keine weiteren direkten
fragen aus dem streaming publikum haben
meistens immer noch eine frage und zwar
zur frage der geschichtsschreibung ist
nur der beginn des letzten sie zur
abstimmung geführt hat und der so an ist
der besteht einigkeit darüber dass sind
ja immer jemanden gegeben hat er damit
angefangen oder das war auch erklären
dass es zu diesen konflikt ist wann
versuch sich südkärnten anzueignen nein
also das war damals ziemlich normal es
ist hier ja also es ist die monarchie
zerbrochen der vielvölkerstaat und man
hat gedacht also die die seligkeit für
alle wird liegen in nationalstaaten als
in staaten mit der wo die leute dieselbe
sprache sprechen dasselbe abstimmung
sind also was ja nie möglich ist und
dass man versucht eben sich zu
auseinanderzudividieren das kleine
deutsche österreich ist geblieben als
deutschsprachiger start im gewisse dinge
wahrnehmen da nicht der hat eben die
kärntner gegeben die kärntner slowenen
die immer schon innerhalb kärntens
gelebt haben die uhr jetzt aber der neue
staat es der zuerst eine ein staaten
slowenen kroaten und serben war nämlich
der leute die innerhalb der monarchie
gelebt haben die haben einen neuen start
gebildet
nach ende der monarchie und zwar im sack
hat mit zentrum zagreb laibach auch
zentral und erst am ersten dezember sind
dann diese
haben also selbstständige königreich
serbien dazu gekommen das hat sich
umgewandelt in sas nämlich die serben an
der spitze es wurde ein königreich also
das hat sich gebildet das sei ganz
normal
so wie sich die die böhmen mähren
schlesische dinge auseinander dividiert
haben also dass hier ansprüche gestellt
worden das war legal vor seiten der des
us-staates weil man wollte eben alles
was süß lahm ich war also alle slowenen
kroaten alle sie haben innerhalb eines
nationalstaates eben eines
jugoslawischen nationalstaatliche sitz
des staates vereinen und das hat niemand
auch was dagegen gefunden
kerner selbst die kerne haben sich als
erstes land konstituiert haben sich
durch österreich angeschlossen und dann
haben in ihrer ersten provisorischen
verfassung dezidiert erklärt also wir
sind zu unserer zu unserem land gehört
so und so und jene slowenischsprachigen
kärntner die sich aber selbst als also
die dann selbst erklären müssen ob sie
zu österreich gehören wollen oder zum
neuen start sas also das steht in
unserer verfassung drinnen in der kerner
verfassung und die pariser konferenz
sollte dann entscheiden wie das
geschehen soll in einer volksabstimmung
oder wie immer also das hat man fixiert
also diese 80.000 zu wähnen
denen hat man zugestanden dass ich
selbst entscheiden wohin sie gehören
wollen
zu deutsch österreich oder zum neuen
sitz lage staat aber schuldzuweisungen
erklären
denn zusammen an diesem punkt beträgt
wenn das ein anderer
was denken immer mädels einen köpfen zu
rektorin eigentlich nicht angebracht
nein ganz sicher nicht nein also immer
wieder auftauchen
nein nein ganz sicher nicht die kerne
haben sich nun zur wehr gesetzt weil
eben nicht nur es war ja man hat sich
die trauer so war als demarkationslinie
ausgemacht nur ist vorsitz frischer
seite von light damals die laibacher
truppen haben also diese
demarkationslinie die vereinbart war
ursprünglich schon 1918 zwischen den
zwei neu entstandenen gebieten
sie haben die überquert und dadurch
kannst du dieses dieses diese
vereinbarung gebrochen und dann hat sich
gerne neben zur wehr gesetzt am 15
dezember ist der beschluss gefallen dass
man sich zur wehr setzen wird wenn es
wenn es keine weiteren fragen mehr gibt
dann habe ich noch eine letzte frage
generalsekretär glaube ich zurecht als
die potsdam der kärntner
geschichtsschreibung der letzten jahre
bezeichnet
sie haben jedoch miterlebt sie die
entwicklung in den letzten jahrzehnten
die deutsch kärntner
geschichtsschreibung zur slowenischen
kärntner slowenisches nicht und
vielleicht könnten sie zum abschluss
auch dazu haben wir sagen wie die beiden
seiten die beiden volksgruppen das
phänomen grenz kämpfe abwehrkampf was
der deutschen sicht kampf um die
nordgrenze des slowenischen sich bis hin
zur volksabstimmung in den letzten
jahrzehnten bewährten und wie sich das
gegensatz
also interessanterweise was den
abwehrkampf an land der wurde ja immer
wieder in frage gestellt aber nicht von
slowenischer seite denn die haben sehr
wohl immer den kampf um die nordgrenze
als gegeben angesehen und haben niemals
so schlechtes wort über den abwehrkampf
verloren
sie haben ihn als solchen akzeptiert
genauso wie man den kampf um die
nordgrenze akzeptiert was haben sie also
wenn das ich richtung die sich ja es war
es war natürlich ursprünglich schon
dieses viel nationale denken sowohl auf
der einen seite in slowenien als auf
unserer seite gegeben aber das hat sich
sehr verbessert nämlich vor allem auch
auf slowenischer seite da gibt es auf
beiden seiten also man sieht dass man
arbeitet zusammen man sieht dass viele
objektiver und heutzutage ist es so dass
ich zum beispiel in meinem letzten
bücher vom geschichtsverein das immer
wieder zweimal im jahr heraus kommt das
ja also im leben hier
die zwei letzten hälfte sind eben mit
dem dem thema abwehr kam volksabstimmung
gewidmet und und ich habe mir gedacht
100 jahre danach was spricht dagegen
oder spricht eigentlich alles dafür dass
man einmal einen kern der slowenischen
eine kärntner slowenen historiker die
hauptpartie gehabt beiträge über die
zeit volksabstimmung abwehrkampf
schreiben lässt und habe einigen gebeten
aber natürlich den ich von kender der
also sehr sehr objektiv immer arbeitet
aber der sehr wohl die slowenische
position vertritt und die usa
die publikation zur volksabstimmung zum
jubiläum von vom geschichtsverein der
also er immer auf die nationale seite
fällt oder gerechnet wurde
da steht jetzt ein da ist jetzt ein
kärntner slowene der die haupt beiträge
in diesem in diesem jubiläums bänden
geschrieben hat und ich finde dass ist
nur richtig nach 100 jahren sollte man
und kann man das so handhaben und das
ist auch gut geworden und es ist auch
von den leuten komischerweise erkannt
worden dass das so dass dahinter ein
zweckbündnis steht und es ist eigentlich
alles immer positiv goutiert worden
ja ich glaube das sind auch sehr
passende worte zum abschluss das wir
glaube ich heute auch eben nach 100
jahren eine doch ein bisschen gelöste
der sich dass manche dinge haben die
passiert sind und gerade auch die zahlen
ohne am samstag hatte sich gezeigt dass
wir auf gutem wege sind mir bleibt nur
noch ganz herzlich dank zu sagen für
ihren vortrag für die teilnahme an der
diskussion für all diejenigen die
tatsächlich vor dem bildschirm verfolgt
haben
auch denen danke fürs zuhören und darf
noch einen schönen abend wünschen danke
auch von meiner seite vielen dank frau
professor für diesen spannenden
geschichte abend ich glaube dass es
vielleicht auch von ihrer warte aus die
lange anreise bei schlechtem wetter aus
kärnten wert war hier heute paar astra
tech ihre sichtweise zu notare kärntner
volksabstimmung dazu lägen dafür vielen
herzlichen dank
ich möchte mich auch bei den zuhörern
und zuseher an eine streaming geräten
sehr herzlich bedanken und hoffe dass
sie auch meiner meinung sind dass das
keine vergeudete zeit war sich mit
diesem wichtigen thema für österreich
geschichte auseinanderzusetzen und ich
darf mir jetzt noch erlauben
als kleinen dank und anerkennung für die
mühen die sie auf sich genommen haben
einen blumenstrauß und dem herrn hofrat
etwas für stille stunden am abend zu
bereiten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
war schön
dank das ja und auch dem publikum
vielen dank fürs heutige herkommen und
für ist die suche dir danke vielmals
dafür sei jetzt noch in gebieten zu
einem foto darf ich die beiden general
dazu bieten